hey guys it's recent we are now getting
a police escort to the track and then I
don't know what's gonna happen so stay
tuned we made it let's go
did you ride in the parade last year
with with grey eyes she was so fun it
was my first time really getting into
the whole IndyCar scene and I got to
ride in the car with grim ray Hall in
the parade and now here I am back again
with Steak N Shake and isn't so much fun
the fastener Bennett Indies like 256
miles out you'll probably go
we are not being in the parade how's it
goin everything's good it's looking
forward to this this is going to be
cooler in Ohio this is tradition all
right
time to change
the red carpet now
we'd set up the red carpet and now we're
gonna head out into the pit and see what
we can see I have nothing to tell you
what to expect because this is all just
happening I don't I have no expectation
you have no expectations great things
happen
so we just escape the pits and we're
inside and the race is about to start
and we're literally two feet away from
the track but yet we have the most
perfect view ever oh no wrong way it's a
video shortly after this we're going to
head over to the snake pit where all the
concerts are going on and the Skrillex
is performing and then after that Martin
garrix is performing unfortunately after
you catch a flight so let's go see scrub
let's go
time to change again new outfit we're
eating lunch watching it there's one lab
this is the final lap okay 500 I cannot
wait I definitely wanna go back next
year thank you so much taking shake for
letting have such an awesome experience
you guys are amazing my gram mixture
buddy next year see you guys later